here at Pioneer middle we have a diverse
group of students focus on six through
eighth grade good job when it comes to
miss Grubbs she is so creative one of
the resources she has used is Khan
Academy with the learn storm this class
mainly focuses on students with learning
needs so we have to come up with
alternative strategies to kind of try to
help those students learn storm is an
excellent resource for differentiation
differentiation it's one of the most
difficult things to accomplish they
expect you to have one person to service
30 people individually I don't
necessarily great accuracy a great
progress so learn storm is a good way to
differentiate and as well as motivate
and with the growth mindset pieces you
can also educate them about why it's
important to learn how they learn how
their body is set up to learn what
strategies help them learn it's amazing
it's amazing in his frame the best part
of doing the lost arm it built up my
confidence to do more do better for
myself be a better person
I think one of the most inspirational
stories was one of my students he was
the first one to complete all sixty
assignments and after he completed those
sixty assignments he asked for more I
did over three hundred lessons in one
week my story is good I felt proud of
myself getting all these good grades
end of each week I assess my students
every single one of them shows
significant progress and their energy
improves significantly because they
believe they can do it now
so they're very very very happy and
pleased with themselves I would
encourage any teacher to utilize learn
storm as a motivational tool for
students to get started try to get that
jump started at the beginning of the
year I mean you want students to get
excited about learning what better way
than the learn storm to get them excited
about learning